[Music]
what are we looking at right here wait
those are three the three little pigs
the three little pigs and the wolf
driving a car which does not happen in
the story sir
do you have wasted everyone's time yeah
but he told the pigs that he was a
vegetarian now that he's not gonna eat
them it is absolutely incredible all
right it's very difficult cuz I had to
paint them with a hair from the dead
flight this is the hair of a dead fly I
painted them with a hair from a dead fly
the fly the fly died of natural causes
who cares I mean that's why I have to
die of natural causes well his family
told me that his wife had left him a
heart attack
[Laughter]
Moving's I want to get I want to show us
in case you're absolutely fascinating
and I want to show a little more before
we completely run out of time what are
we going to see here little shock oh
this is Shaquille O'Neal yeah a shrunken
okay oh my god
what's wrong with his biceps so
[Laughter]
everyone's a critic no giving you a hard
time you've made something it's
microscopically small and I'm not giving
you a hard time but I call this one
shrunken Shrek yeah
wearing overly large shorts but it's
that's absolutely incredible and then I
think we have time for I just want to
show one more you used a let's let's
show this one right here because this is
fascinating you actually used is this a
you used real found object is that
correct and this one says I may have to
change the position of this one okay
because it's here this one I call the
Equality because you can see there's a
there's a little black girl a little
white girl on the seesaw and they're
both balanced I'll call that equality
because that's a racial harmony in the
eye of the needle because
[Applause]
and they're not arguing over the Cecil
they're just wondering why they're in
the eye of a needle
all right well I think we have one more
thing that we wanted to show which is
your watch you've actually put a tiny
image in your wife yeah this is a I work
with a company called Gruber and four so
make the most incredible watches in the
world and I did a co-creation with them
this is a working prototype and inside
this I've inserted one of my sculptures
what I do if people are interested in
one of my piece of artwork it goes
inside the watch now this is the most
amazing watch in the world if you
Hannibal if you haven't looked through
the microscope in there you'll see I'll
get to your eye and have a look oh my
eye I thought you wanted me to put it in
the night no okay so this is just
something if you open it up to your eye
there yeah oh my goodness there's a
little well it's weird to do on
television something only I can enjoy
felt to be amazing if you saw this
but you can't there's a little face in
here it's absolutely incredible so
there's a magnifying glass what an
extraordinary gift thank you so much I
can only assume that you'd mean to give
this to me - what this is worth well if
you wanted to know it'd be about one and
half a million again extraordinarily
kind of you but I mean that is studies
the price haven't been full of fix but
it's around about that price yeah I mean
it is the most exquisite watch in the
world because it's it's got my work in
and it's made by the best watchmakers in
the world
nicely done Warren this economy you'll
sell plenty of them